Mohammad over soon bismillah al
hamdulillah assalamu alaikum peace be
unto you thank you again for tuning in
to another episode of the Dean show all
thanks and praises to the creator of the
heavens and the earth who's given us
this ability this platform to be with
you today to talk about many of the
truths of Islam now one crucial thing
that's very important is that we know
that God Almighty throughout time he is
a loving and merciful God adjust guy and
he has manifested as by throughout time
sending through his messengers what he
wants from us how he wants us to live
and the many rewards in the lights that
are waiting for those who strive their
utmost to be upright and honest and live
a godly life not according to your whims
and desires but life according to how
the creator of the heavens and earth
wants you to live now we as Muslims we
believe in the Torah which was given to
Moses peace be upon him in its original
we believe in the injeel some
translators the gospel that Gospels
which was given to Jesus Christ peace be
upon him and what was given of the
scripture to Abraham was given to dawood
David peace be upon him all and what was
given what we have is a living miracle
today intact the verbatim word of God
the Quran which has been memorized by
millions and we did a show on this
giving you the overwhelming amount of
evidence to show you and to prove to you
that the Quran is indeed the verbatim
word of God but today we want to talk
about the Bible we want to talk about
this book to examine it to see is this
indeed the word of the creator of the
heavens and earth what is it so to help
cover this very important topic is our
good friend and brother who's bender
wassup with us before he has a special
section at the Dean show calm dr. gerald
Dierks he is a doctor in clinical
psychology amongst that he has graduated
with honors from the prestigious Harvard
University with the masters in divinity
finished seminary school and the list
goes on we're going to bring them out to
help us tackle this topic on a closer
look into the Bible we'll be right back
on the danger Allah there's only one
word and Muhammad is His Messenger a la
la
ah ha there's only one but Jesus was his
messenger no I did that maybe it maybe
it's just to break the ice peace be unto
you and peace up to you belong when I
can thank you very much for being was
here on a Dean show now tell us briefly
quickly many people already know who you
are but there are some people that have
just tuned in for the first time and
they want to know who was this person
and how is he qualified to talk about
the Bible well as you mentioned in your
introduction i received a Master of
Divinity degree from Harvard Divinity
School I was an ordained minister in the
United Methodist Church and converted to
Islam in 1993 okay now break this down
for us what is the Methodist Church well
the United Methodist Church is one of
the Protestant denominations in
Christianity is that the largest
denomination no at one time it was back
in the 60s it was the largest Protestant
denomination in America now it's
probably second second what's the first
southern baptist Southern Baptist and
then now then Methodists will come after
that problem you were filling the
congregation the Pope is I mean you walk
there you were preaching and teaching
the Bible yes so you were would they say
or a Bible where they say a bible
thumper no I was never a bible thump
what does that mean when you say five of
the word well that's sort of a
colloquialism for someone who is
constantly preaching from the Bible and
constantly filling his sermons with
biblical verses so they can see your
story hear your story on how you
accepted Islam but today we were
intrigued we want to know because as I
when I introduce the show we talked
about these scriptures that were given
revelations to the messengers and intact
the originals we believe but these were
from the crater but the Bible how do we
approach it what is the Bible that we
have today is this the Word of God well
I think there's a prior question we have
to ask brother tell me and that is which
Bible which Bible which Bible and when I
say that I'm not saying
king james version versus New Revised
Standard Version that's simply different
translations now in the New Revised
Standard Version they go back to earlier
Greek manuscripts than the King James
Version deal so you get a more authentic
translation but basically it's different
translations but the reality is that
Christianity has never agreed on what
constitutes the Bible so if we look
there's two main parts of the Bible the
Old Testament the New Testament if we
look at the Old Testament the Protestant
Bible has 39 books mm-hmm in the Old
Testament now to that the Roman
Catholics add several books those being
amongst others first and second
Maccabees Tobit Judith ecclesiasticus
the wisdom of Solomon and baruch and
over and above those books that they had
to the Old Testament they add additions
to the Book of Daniel they add additions
to the book of Esther that's the Roman
Catholic Bible Roman Catholic so it has
a total of how many books things where
you have to add them up is that all 77
no no well not in the Old Testament okay
and the Greek Orthodox they add even
more than the Roman Catholic due to the
Old Testament so for example they had a
150 first Psalm Protestant Roman
Catholic Bibles in with 150 Psalms but
they had a hundred and fifty first first
song they add material to the Book of
Jeremiah that doesn't exist in either
the Protestant or the Roman Catholic
Bible now we're talking about that's the
Old Testament we're strict sticking to
the Old Testament okay gotcha they also
add third and fourth Maccabees that's
not found in the Roman Catholic Bible
and they add first esdras in the prayer
of Manasseh neither of which is found in
the Roman Catholic Bible so these are
books that are in one Bible they're not
in the other paths right okay and then
when we go to something like the
Ethiopian Orthodox Church we discover a
radically different Old Testament now
the the Ethiopian Orthodox Church
had a canon of about forty six books I
think it was whereas the Protestants
have 39 in their Old Testament and they
included things such as Jubilees
Ethiopian Enoch sudo jofi Josephus the
Ezra apocalypse and these aren't found
in any of the other Bibles that we've
been talking about so in terms of the
Old Testament Christianity has never
agreed as to what constitutes the Old
Testament the Christianity has also
never agreed as to what constitutes the
New Testament now in the Protestant
Roman Catholic in Greek Orthodox Bibles
they all agree and say there are 27
books to the New Testament however the
Coptic Orthodox Church adds first and
second Clement to the New Testament
giving a 29 book canon to the New
Testament the East Syrian or an
historian church omits five books that
are found in the Protestant Roman
Catholic in Greek Orthodox Bible they
they do not recognize second Peter
second and third John Jude in Revelation
you won't find that those books in their
new testament and the ethiopian orthodox
church again a fairly radically
different New Testament they say there's
35 books in their new testament and they
include things like first second third
and fourth Synod owes the first and
second book of the Covenant Calla mentos
the shepherd of hermas etc books that
are not found in any other churches
Bible so Christianity has never agreed
as to what constitutes the Bible and as
to why that's the case we can talk about
that if you want or we can go on with
whatever other questions you have tell
us now it's presumed that Moses he was
the author of the first five book is
this true the first five books of the
old test Old Testament yeah the first
book of virtuous called Genesis by
Christianity
well you know we know he didn't write
all of it because it says at one point
and Moses died so we know Moses didn't
write that you know that's been sort of
the traditional legendary origin of
these five books that the this was the
Torah that God gave to Moses peace be
upon it so this is not tutorial but no
this is not the original Torah that was
given to Moses now first five books of
the Bible the first five books of the
Bible Genesis Exodus Leviticus numbers
and Deuteronomy what's called the Torah
today by Jews and Christians is actually
a cut-and-paste compilation from earlier
source material those sources usually
identified as being je d & p je was
written around the Year 950 BCE II
around 750 BCE d in the 600's BCE p in
the 400 and 500 BCE and they were
finally put together sometime around the
year 400 these four sources in a
cut-and-paste fashion now Moses peace be
upon him live depending upon how you
figure your chronology from the biblical
dates somewhere from around 1600 BCE at
the earliest through around maybe 1200
BCE of the latest 1622 12 to 1200 I'm
were in that range with Moses and these
are coming by the oldest part J is from
950 BCE so this would be home at least
250 years after Moses after the fat
least okay minimum so it's safe to say
now and when did you start to learn this
information was this while you were up
on the pulpit preaching and teaching or
was it his come later in seminary
students in seminary this was in
seminary you know there's a very
interesting verse in the Old Testament
that says that Ezra came from the
Babylonian captivity back to Palestine
AR on the Year 397 398 BCE and he
brought with him the law or the Torah
because it had been totally lost and
forgot
in Palestine amongst the Jews that
remained there most modern biblical
scholars say that the Torah as we know
it today not the original Torah given to
Moses but the Torah as we have it today
in those first five books of the Old
Testament was a cut-and-paste
compilation from earlier source material
it was put together in Babylon during
the Babylonian captivity and reached its
final form around the Year 400 BCE and
that this is what Ezra brought back with
him to Palestine so those are the five
books what are the books that come after
these five well in the traditional
Jewish way of addressing it there are
three parts to the Old Testament ok
there's the Torah which we've already
talked about then there's the nevian or
the prophets and the Jews didn't agree
until what constituted the prophets
until probably the 2nd century BCE and
then there's the kids avene or the
writings this would be things like
Psalms proverbs chronicles Song of
Solomon etc and the Jews didn't really
used to be thought that they finalized
the canon of what went into the kit
devine at the council of jam me around
the Year 90 but more modern biblical
scholarship is now saying that probably
went on for a while after the council of
jam neum maybe for a century or two well
the Roman Catholic Church when it
constructed its Old Testament you know
there weren't very many people around to
read Hebrew at that point yeah and so
what they did they went to something
called the Septuagint now the Septuagint
was a Greek translation of Hebrew
Scripture and writing that word I was
done by Jews in alexandria egypt around
the Year 300 BCE so this was well before
the Jews had finalized deciding what was
and wasn't in there canon of scripture
and so these Jews as they were
translating they used a number of books
that didn't make it into the final
Jewish set of Scripture
well when the Roman Catholic Church went
to construct its Old Testament and they
use the Greek Septuagint they
automatically accepted everything that
was in it which included these books
like first and second Maccabees Judith
and Tobin that's not in the Jewish body
of Scripture as we have it today when
the Protestant Reformation took over
1400 1500 s the Protestants basically
said well you know why are we fooling
around with this Greek Septuagint you
know let's go to the the Hebrew text and
as a result of doing that they ended up
with an old testament that was shorter
than that that the Roman Catholic said
so tell us now for the layman I mean we
want to know just like in a court of law
you want to bring forth the witnesses
you want to examine their truthfulness
you want to see their biography who
these people are can we trust them so we
can submit to whatever God Almighty is
telling us to submit to we don't as you
said what's allegedly called the Torah
okay these books now from what we're
understanding was not written and could
not have been written by Moses know the
rest of the boats out there may be bits
and pieces etc that are part of that
original thora that someone had
memorized that's possible how about the
books that follow do we know who these
authors are in many cases we do we don't
in many cases we so we can't bring them
forward to cross-examine them to know
their life to another history now we
can't we can't you know books such as
first and second Samuel first and second
Kings Deuteronomy we know these books
were written or authored by Israelites
that were part of what we call today the
Deuter anomic school but who they were
specifically we don't know their names
we don't know this is a fact anyone who
wants to take the time to research this
stuff is known it's out there yeah now
the jewish talmud or oral tradition that
later got codified and written down it
gives legendary authors to most of these
books
but again modern biblical scholarship
doesn't accept it it legendaries you
learn most of this in almost all of it
in seminary for sure okay now tell us to
go a little bit further tell us if
somebody wants to look now towards the
New Testament do we have the same thing
that's happening here with the author's
because many people will say okay
Matthew the Gospel according to Matthew
the Gospel according to mark the Gospel
according to accelerate cetera these
were the actual disciples and this is
probably the majority of Christendom
they will say that this these are the
disciples of Jesus who are writing these
books is this true yeah this is what
most Christians really okay but
unfortunately it's not true it's not
true not true at all steak the first
book of the New Testament the Gospel of
Matthew wasn't written as far as we know
by Matthew who was a disciple of Jesus
we really don't know who wrote it it was
written around the Year say 80 85 siiii
and it in turn is a compilation of
earlier sources q proto mark and m the
first mention that we have anywhere that
Matthew wrote a gospel comes from around
the Year 120 when one of the early
bishops said Matthew the disciple of
Jesus peace be upon him wrote the
sayings of Jesus in Hebrew and then
later tradition associated that
statement with the first gospel in the
New Testament and Matthews name got
affixed to it though the Matthew we have
is not in Hebrew it was in Greek and
it's far more than simply sayings of
Jesus so there really is no logical or
evidence evidence to link Matthews name
with the Gospel of Matthew the same
thing is true of the other Gospels John
apparently written by someone named John
but whether that was John the disciple
of Jesus
is very questionable the books that we
do have some known authorship for are
the letters of Paul though he's often
credited with writing more of those
letters than he actually did so even
those books by Paul like Hebrews Hebrews
was not written by Paul though legend
associates Hebrew with Paul but Paul did
write Romans he did write first and
second Corinthians he did write
Galatians now by scholarship at the
highest levels is this something what
you're saying that this is agreed upon
or is there now differences of opinions
oh you know you may find a few extreme
members of the Christian Right who will
dispute this but the most all biblical
scholars of mainline Christianity
acknowledge this now going back quickly
to the Old Testament so we don't have
anything original of a document I gave
her those bits and piece missing pieces
yeah okay so the trick is knowing which
bit in which piece okay sits confusion
here now we go back to the to the New
Testament and we do and like I always
try to stress in the shows I mean do we
believe that there is some of the Word
of God in the Bible sure of course we do
but again the trick is determining
voices which you know many of the
sayings attributed to Jesus in the
Gospels of the New Testament probably
many of them actually were said by Jesus
to be about it yeah but again which were
which weren't which were added later
which reflects the teachings of the
early Pauline church and not the actual
teachings of Jesus these are the sorts
of questions that biblical scholars
wrestle with what about the red letter
edition is this now accurately what
Jesus said the red letter bible well
it's what is attributed to Jesus in the
New Testament but whether Jesus actually
said all of those things or not we we
really don't know have you heard of this
Jesus Seminar sure what did this this is
so knows about biblical scholars and
interested lay people who get together
and vote
on which statements attributed to Jesus
they think he actually said mm-hmm and
what today did they come up with a
percentage number they have yes what was
the percentage that day well you know
give this a subject to to argument and
dispute among biblical scholars yeah but
suffice it to say that we don't have
absolute proof on any of these things
what we have our second hand third and
fourth hand information and and we don't
have the chain of transmission yeah for
this information you know we don't have
anything that says I received it from
so-and-so who received it from so-and-so
who received it from so-and-so that
Jesus said this so that we have this
provenance that we can go check yeah
kind of like what we have a stringent
meticulous chain of narrations in Islam
where you have the person's biography
yes if you had a bad memory you throw
this person's hadi for saying out I mean
you know everything if this person
prayed five times everything about this
person you're talking about the sayings
of Prophet my peace be upon him and yes
that's called a hadith and there's two
parts to every hadith yeah there's the
Mattin or the narrative mm-hmm you know
the messenger of god peace be upon him
said and then the rest of it but before
that comes what's called the Assad or
the chain and this is the chain of
transmission of the provenance of this
say you know abdullah ibrahim on
received it from so-and-so who received
it from so-and-so who received it from
so-and-so who heard it directly from the
prophecy contain a link yeah and you can
go check who in all these person yes not
only who they are but can we ever put
them at the same place at the same time
hmm if we can't do that then when I got
a better d okay yeah this wasn't done
here with the oh we got we don't have
any chain of transmission so what we
have in the Gospels is basically hadith
but without the provenance
now if we take this again and we use
rationale and we do what we do now is a
civilized society and we bring it to a
court of law and we want to
cross-examine the witnesses can we do it
well it's it's a we don't have like a
third fourth hand information okay so
now a person says you know what you got
to have faith brother yes what do you
say and if faith is a wonderful thing
yeah but reason and rationality are also
wonderful things yeah and the two really
should go hand in hand so you want to
before you have faith in something you
want to have evidence to back that its
knowledge base faith is that correct
well certainly the Quran he always tells
us you know reason reason about this
reason about this use your observations
etc so yes I mean one would prefer that
reason and faith coexists and point to
the same together now do we have which
we actually do it's interesting because
you see this confusion here like I said
we are not trying to step on nobody's
toes but this information is out there
and it should be known now what we have
in the verbatim word of God the Quran
which is kept intact since it was
revealed memorized by millions all over
the world you have a verse in there that
God Almighty Allah is saying that whoa
those that write the book with their
hands yes and gain a miserly price woe
to them for what their hands do right
and woe to them for what they profit
from but we see this going on yeah we
certainly do and we can see this
specifically in terms of some places in
the Bible where we know when something
was added you know why it was at it we
even know where it was added give us
some examples now if I can reach over
here to King James version of the Bible
yes and I'm using this one because King
James Version is from a late greek
source manuscript not an early one and
this is what you'll find in the king
james version for there are three that
bear record in heaven
the father the word in the Holy Ghost
and these three are one and there are
three that bear witness in earth the
spirit and the water and the blood and
these three agree in one now that's what
you find and that service is that this
is a first John chapter 5 verses 7 and 8
yeah and that certainly sounds like the
Trinity doesn't it yes okay but this is
a late greek manuscript that they're
translating from now if we go to the New
Revised Standard Version of the Bible
which goes back to much earlier
manuscripts and we look at the same
exact verse we find this there are three
that testify the spirit and the water
and the blood in these three agree and
that's it everything about the Father of
the Son and the Holy Ghost and being in
heaven and these three are one that's a
later edition that does not exist in the
oldest manuscripts and in this
particular case we know when this was at
it it was added around the Year 380 it
was added in Spain in a manuscript in
Spain and from there went into the Latin
Vulgate Jerome's translation of the
Bible into Latin and then subsequently
was picked up from Latin sources and
some late greek manuscripts which is how
it got into the king james version but
the original there's absolutely no
mention of the Father the Son and the
Holy Spirit what's the one from I
believe its marked towards the end where
you have bits whole chunks that but or
not it's the last part of mark the last
chapter of mark most of the early
manuscripts end with verse 8 this is
chapter 16 verse 8 that's where it ends
but in later manuscripts it goes on from
chapter from verse 9 2 verse 20 talking
about the resurrection of Jesus this is
a big later edition
to the these are no facts how about the
story of the adulterer and adulterous oh
and John yeah doesn't exist in the
earliest managed but one where Jesus
says how does it go he said those those
without sin cast the first stone yeah
wonderful story beautiful story the
entire chapter is a later edition
doesn't exist and the earliest
manuscripts that we have I mean this is
a something profound I mean it's amazing
any sincere person what should he do now
what does he do he's confused you've
confused some people some people knew it
from the from the get-go I mean where do
we go from here now well a person needs
to study and this is what I would advise
any Christian to do study your Bible and
study a good translation of the Bible
and the one I would recommend is the New
Revised Standard Version because it does
go back to some of the earliest
manuscripts that we have and then get a
good bible commentary one that's done by
scholars such as the interpreters one
volume commentary on the Bible published
around 1974 i think it was or 1971 study
these there's no substitute for study
become familiar with your own Scripture
and as many converts to islam have
discovered by studying the bible this
was actually one of the things that led
them to islam this is amazing how could
someone go further into looking into
this topic that we had just discussed in
one of your books do you go more depth
into this and to the issue of the Bible
yeah in the cross and the crescent there
is no chapter that talks about comparing
the Quran with the Torah and with the
the Gospels and most of those think you
mentioned amongst more things they're in
here many things are in there okay any
closing comments and suggestions that
you can give well i would say read
carefully study the bible carefully and
don't go on automatic pilot when you
read so for example the the famous
lineage of jesus that's given in the
first
after Matthew and he says so-and-so
beget so-and-so beget so-and-so beget so
and so and then he gets towards the end
of that and he says some very
significant words he says so all the
generations from Abraham to David are
fourteen generations and from David to
the deportation to Babylon fourteen
generations and from the deportation to
Babylon to the Messiah fourteen
generations count them there's not 14 in
each set there's 14 only in two of the
sets there's 13 in one of the sense so
read critically do not simply read an
automatic pilot and don't just take
everything what anything about you think
about it and this is something that you
after going through you know Harvard
Divinity going through seminary that you
were exposed to this but now someone
doesn't have to go through all that I
mean luckily they got to tune in and
they're getting to hear it here so thank
you for being a fuss my pleasure brother
Thank You doc lahaina we got a mighty
reward you in abundance and like to
thank you for coming to the Dean show to
learn more about islam and muslims and
to learn about some of these truths one
main thing that you can do to make it
simple is to humble yourself and ask the
one who is all knowing who knows was
deep in your heart as the one who
created you alone to guide you to make
things clear and it'd only be fair that
he got you if you humble yourself and
your ass and then do like I guess said
study put some time aside from the
material world and the rat race that's
out there you're going to die one day
should be prepared for what's coming
next God Almighty as we said earlier he
sent messengers and the last and final
messenger is set to mankind is the
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him that
is a son of God not as the right-hand
man of God but as a teacher just like
Jesus was Moses was Abraham was they
were all teachers teaching us how to get
close to God you're going to have to
talk to yourself and
really ask yourself what's my purpose in
life why am I here and start to ask
these more serious questions and want to
get to know what the truth really is not
just sliding in and go in with the flow
so these are things that you're going to
have to want to do on your own and we
hope that we can be of assistance so
come and visit us here every week on the
Dean show until next time peace be unto
you no speech is better than to do that
was call people to Allah and to do there
were no speeches better you know nothing
is better than that is it true that if
one person I'm the Allah giving you the
ability to guide so much for the lost
permission the craters permission that
was better than everything in this world
but in the whole world and everything
that's in it in another narration it's
better than the best of wealth but if we
really felt that Eddie would we not be
getting out getting done and this is
something that we encourage all the msas
all the dowel organizations the musjid
forget this we want to prep more we give
these to the non mrs. for free for free
for free we want our brothers it's cold
it lay everybody sleeping I arise and
ask a lot of thinking me Omar you see
hola you know all the sins I do I turn
to you to figure my sing tomorrow i'm
using for slave you're my love
runs away all the guide me